all right Brooklyn well how excited are
you to get into the fall gig to talk to
me from the comfort of your own home I
mean this is this is my life now
drag from the waist up in my living room
is it just the waist up that's always
just the waist up after many years of
dreaming it's official we're looking for
Canada's first drag superstar you're
bringing us some entertainment in this
time of quarantine will have Canada's
drag race to watch every week starting
this Thursday
ah talk to me about how this show came
into your life because you are the first
Aroo Girl to make the transition to
behind the judge's table I know it's
just crazy to think about in 11 seasons
I'm the first one which is amazing well
this kind of it happened the first time
I had even thought about it or talked to
anybody anybody about it was right after
we filmed a season 11 of RuPaul's Drag
Race
and it was August probably I guess that
would be 2018 at that point and I was in
the world of wonder offices and I was
just talking with them about shows I
could maybe do one Wow presents Plus and
then I said you know what I would really
love it if there was a Canada's drag
race I know that's like Oh a long shot
it's never gonna happen but I'm just
saying and I'm putting it into the
universe it'd be so fun and they were
like ha ha ha yeah maybe one day we'll
see
just kind of like shrugged it off so and
I didn't think any more about it and
then I think it was right after the
finale in May or June of 2019 and my
agent calls me in there and he was like
so there's gonna be a candidate drag
race and they're just finalizing it and
they want to know if you would be a
judge and I just my jaw just like
dropped in my apartment I could not
believe it like I was so gagged that
this was actually like happening and
like happening right after the finale
had kind of finished so I was like so I
was like oh great well what am I gonna
do now I guess I'll go back on all-stars
and then this kind of just plopped in my
lap and I yeah I could not be more
grateful or excited to eat chosen to do
this and Canada's drag race there's no
room behind that
desk you're the drag queen so what kind
of pressure is that I it's a lot of
pressure I mean I think the important
thing is to realize that I am NOT RuPaul
I'm not trying to be recall I could
never be RuPaul so I as soon as I kind
of realized that in myself I kind of was
like I'm just gonna go and I'm gonna be
Brooklyn I'm gonna do it more than does
and that's gonna work so that's what
that's what I did and it worked out
really well I was just myself and had a
really really good time doing it it was
so amazing to be able to do with Jeffery
and Stacey together I could not have
asked for better code judges to judge
this with me we had so much fun
Queen - Queen I know the pressure of
this competition but I can promise you
it's gonna be worth it this is your time
to shine this experience will change
your life completely what would you say
is harder competing on the show or
judging the show
Oh competing for sure would you ever
want to go back and compete now knowing
the judges side of things oh you know I
don't know I don't know that it would
make sense
um like I definitely not well I'm a
judge like right now is kind of I kind
of feel like I've moved beyond competing
a little bit in this moment I'm I don't
think would make any sense for me to go
back well Canada's drag race still going
on but Never Say Never
I mean if I had to go back and compete I
would I I just don't think it's gonna be
anytime soon what insights to the
competition did you get from judging
that you were like oh this is something
I didn't realize until I sat on the
other side of how nervous we all look I
think the first week I was like all
right y'all need to calm down like yeah
you good just everyone was just like
like these like you could just you could
feel the nerves coming off these girls
just like waiting it's like one by one
we went down the line and I've been
chosen you guys seem - can everyone just
shake it out for a second like it's okay
like no one's going to die today like
just just breathe like I just never
realized like how nervous how nervous we
all look standing up there and how much
you can see people's nerves when they're
just kind of like especially when they
know when you know that they know that
they did a bad job or they're just
waiting for it did RuPaul give you any
advice before you
into this experience um I saw last time
I saw him was at the Emmys last year and
I forgot to ask him for advice because
he's RuPaul and I was like hi it's great
to see a live video I'm like I just I
didn't I just forgot it like slipped my
mind
I did ask Michelle for some advice
though I'm Michelle and she's an amazing
amazing judge and she was just she said
just see yourself in the contestants and
be honest I was just gave I made sure to
give very I tried to give very
constructive criticism when it was
necessary and some of them were harsh
but it was know never came from a mean
place and I always made sure that was
very evident it was always from a place
of wanting to help them be better and
then when they did well I got so excited
when I would see someone - well when I
would see since we're a fierce-looking I
made sure to let them know how excited I
was at how well they were doing I think
you just need that and I know that US -
contestant you need you're sitting there
craving you just want the approval you
want them to say good you did a really
good job because you're trying so hard
so I know what that feels like when you
get a good compliment from a judge yes
so I made sure to let them know when
they did it good jobs would you say
you're judging style is similar to
Michelle's a little bit I think I'm I
think I'm a mix of all of them because I
gave it definitely gave critiques that I
also gave a lot of enthusiastic grace
ooh my cat literally just jumped up on
this thing sorry whoa I gave a lot of I
feel like I was pretty well-rounded so
there was a little bit of your shell
peppered in there with some Carson and
some crew and some Ross they just threw
them all in a blender it that's what
happened and made Brooklyn Michelle
comes to play as a guest judge so what
is it like bringing her onto Canadian to
her and having her read the girls so
good it's honestly like a master class
you were fashion but funny and I loved
that Michelle is the goat like she she
is such so so so good at her job like I
learned so much I mean because within
the thing with TV you have a certain
amount of time and there is so much I
wanted to say to the girls every week
that a lot of times when you're giving
critiques you could just
gamble and just talk talk and they're
like okay yeah we got to wrap it up like
we can't use any of that and Michelle
was so good at saying exactly what she
wanted to say it was so cool to watch
her do that to be like okay that's kind
of what I need to work on with my
judging style and she was great
like she her critiques are amazing she's
she had like a page of notes for each
girl I'm like how do you have time to
write all these - she's like I've been
doing it for a decade I figured out it
look it wasn't even looking at the page
just writing it was like work I feel
like it's safe to say we're gonna get a
lot of what we know and love about
RuPaul's Drag Race
on Canada's Drag Race like we'll see the
challenges we know what's gonna surprise
us so that's Canada's drag race what's
different I think the biggest difference
is the fact that Roo isn't there and
that you have Stacey Jeffery and myself
I think that's the really the biggest
difference everything else is very much
the same formula of the show that you
know and love we have a lot of the same
challenges we have snatch game and other
things like that and I will say snatch
game it is the episode I am so excited
for everyone to see that episode because
they absolutely killed it so did they
did they pick a lot of Canadian
superstars to portray no actually they
did not know smart because the music and
the passion it just dropped me in and I
feel so alive yeah when I sing that song
where's the Celine it ain't even Celine
Dion anymore Celine you're done they did
not but yeah it was I was just blown
away because I was really nervous
obviously for them cuz I had a little
PTSD going into it and they were just
incredible they did such a good job and
I was so proud after that episode I was
wow you y'all really proved yourself
skier cuz that's like the episode
everyone watch a store oh yeah a hundred
percent what surprised you the most
about the experience surprised me that I
think the hardest thing was I didn't
realize how hard it would be to send
somebody home that was surprisingly
difficult
my evil part of me was like oh this is
gonna be fun and then it like it
happened and I was like oh this sucks it
was
really especially that first week like
the first time we had to do it oh man it
was really tough I actually cried the
next day like I was in my dressing room
the next day and one of the producers
came in I was like how are you feeling I
get it I know I know how hard they
worked I know how much money they spent
like I get it I get it I get it
and like how badly they wanted it and
then that's to get there and then be
like no just kidding just like oh that
sucks so but I got easier as time went
on so it was just that first week was
just it was it was a hard one for me so
that I think that was the thing that
surprised me the most about it well and
you and 100-plus other Queens have
proven you don't have to win the show to
turn it into a platform that will change
your life
exactly but you don't think that in that
moment you think your life is over so
but ya know it's very true it's all it's
all what you do with it and the impact
you've left on the audience and whatever
time you've been there so do you and
your co judges kind of have like equal
power without there being a roux there
it's the three of you a triumvirate
exactly yeah we all have no it has more
power than anybody else like everything
that's very much a democracy we make
every decision together and sometimes
those decisions are quick and then
sometimes those decisions take an hour
and like you just there's but we have a
list we have lists of pros and cons and
pie graphs and charts and like
everything you can think of like we
really take it all very seriously which
I think we need to like this is not a
joke to us we take our decisions
extremely seriously and we really weigh
all the pros and cons to wrap things up
here if you had to boil down Canada's
drag race to one word what's your word
for it
iconic I will take an iconic Canada's
drag race yes are we Americans gonna
need any like slang defined for us have
to pick up on some stuff not a lot of
slang I think it's just more
pronunciation like how you just
pronounced pronunciation creation yes
out about sorry eh I have to tie back
into when I used to watch Degrassi and
they would say things like
adult exactly a process yes okay so
we'll just be by the end of it we'll all
be saying long OHS exactly that's all
you really do well congratulations I
can't wait to watch and hopefully the
world gets better soon and you can get
back out there and perform for the
people I hope so but for now enjoy not
having to talk thank you my balls
appreciate it
[Music]